in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape my guest in the
studio today has saved many many
patients who suffered from a heart
attack and has made it his priority to
educate about the warning signs and
about treatments dr. D Trish and Liz and
thank you very much for being our guest
hello doctor and reason why do so many
people die of a heart attack what
happens there in the body well if you
just remember the mechanism of a
myocardial infarction or the heart
attack it is an occlusion of the
coronary arteries II in this corner
artery if it is good it doesn't support
with oxygen and new treats the muscle
the muscle will die they must will be
distracted and the consequence for the
patient is that the patient will die
from an acute heart failure this one
explanation one cause of death because
the heart muscle doesn't get enough
oxygen nutrients because the arteries
are closed up and visit and cannot pump
any more blood in them in the body the
second one is the so-called sudden
cardiac death that abruptly occurs is so
called tribulation the heart standstill
the patient will collapse within seconds
and if he's not resuscitated he will die
from sudden cardiac death this is the
most reason for dying during the acute
myeloid reason okay so we we do not
agree do need to get treatment straight
away what are warning signs that should
send you to the doctor well the warning
signs are chest pain pain in the chest
however it must not be a major pain it
could be minor one and sometimes is its
radiating to the arms left arm right arm
sometimes in the back however even minor
symptoms can in the indication for
myocardial infarction or heart attack so
even if you have these minor symptoms
you're not sure whether
you just you know not feeling up to it
or whether you have a car for something
it's better to go and see your doctor
and ask for ambulance to bring you in
the hospital they will make an EKG
electrocardiogram and see whether that's
Emma and myocardial infarction a heart
attack or not okay so it's better to
call the doctor better to be safe than
sorry there tell us once you've called
the ambulance is say you you suspect it
yourself or someone around you might be
suffering from a heart attack you call
an ambulance that's the first thing you
do what do you do then well their window
should be open the patients would be in
a composition and then stay with the
patient let him not alone why not
because he suddenly abruptly can be
unconscious and if these unconscious you
have to bring them on the bottom of the
flower floor and then start
resuscitation how do you do this you
have to to bring your your hand or left
hand on the sternum in the middle of the
sternum the right hand you put on the
left hand and then you pump you press
you compress the sternum down at least
five centimeters with a frequency about
100 per minute so deep and and and fast
enough and this you do until the
emergency system arrives okay so keep
the blood flowing through the body to
keep the body filled up with nutrients
basically that's what you're doing there
alright well many many of our viewers
have written in with questions for that
topic one of them was a viewer from New
Zealand Angelique michu's she wanted to
know whether heart attack is actually
hereditary yes far today it is it is we
know that family members fathers and
mothers who suffer from myocardial
infarction the the risk of a kit of
children's are as high as the the
parents head this so we know that this
genetic factor for developing myocardial
function however there are other risk
factors like smoking and hypertension
diabetes these are other risk factors
which had the which can lead to the
myocardial
okay so just briefly tell us if you get
a patient in the hospital who has a
heart attack what sort of treatment do
you perform the only thing you have to
do reopen the vessel reopen time is
muscle reopen the vessel and this will
be done in our laboratory with so-called
cutta cutta categorization and this is
the only chance to get the patient or
for any complications doctor and listen
what's your view on stem cell therapy
well I think it's a promising treatment
however we are far away from solving
this problem but there's a long way to
go but I think in five to ten years we
could have solved most of these problems
we have today okay so five to ten years
that's still a while to go what about
today what about patients who who's had
is week after having suffered a heart
attack well if the patient suffers from
heart failure after the after the heart
attack we have very excellent
medications rather fresh ones who are
helpful alone and in combination to
treat the patient with such a disease
hot name in a mini heart failure mm-hmm
to just strengthen the weak heart
basically yeah what about what's being
researched is the other any promising
new therapies beyond stem cell therapy
that could give hope to patients with a
weak heart after a heart attack well we
look for another newer medications as
well so there's a lot of done in the
last in the past and it will be done in
the future and I guess that artificial
heart development will could be a part
of this investigations and research so
to have completely artificial heart
which is completely implanted in the
body this could be the future for
patients who suffer from really weak we
can drink a weak heart and have a huge
heart failure okay alright so that's
something to look forward to i guess but
for now many viewers have written in
asking questions about how to prevent a
heart attack in the first place and
cholesterol is something that comes to
mind their we've had cardigan hard from
the US and
racine cap Cabo from job and for example
beyond other people asking what role
cholesterol plays when it comes to the
risk for heart attacks the great role
control is a risk factors the mighty
risk factor of all the others as well
smoking as well of course and we have to
do everything to reduce the cultural
level even before you have a heart
attack so afterwards of course it is
very very important and just to bring
the cholesterol level down to 85
milligram per cent this is a very low
level and you cannot do it by eating
special diet rather than by taking
medication against the collateral level
what role does the diet play when it
comes to cholesterol present there's a
role of course but I wouldn't it
overestimate because ten percent only
ten percent of the cholesterol is
getting by by nutrition in your body
ninety percent are builded and in the
liver so so its genetic how much
cholesterol yeah dude we have to to
bring down take medication in the liver
okay um what else can you do to prevent
a heart attack you you take medication
to lower your cholesterol levels what
else is there stop smoking it's really
important we have seen that in countries
who were a lot of patients stop smoking
we have a reduction of the heart attacks
bring down the arterial hypertension and
of course know your profession yeah and
those who with diabetes of course page
and have to treat the diabetes this is
so the treatment of the so-called risk
factors are the treatment of choice okay
well that's lots we can do for ourselves
to prevent a heart attack thank you very
much for being our guest today drop down
please and thanks for your time
you
you